all right we already talked about the
Fox News defamation suit is not going to
conclude with a with a trial verdict uh
the trial started and very quickly they
settled it 787 and a half million
dollars we also talked about uh the last
minute strategy wherein Fox lawyers were
trying to introduce evidence essentially
blaming Donald Trump for the claims that
were made on air okay we have now gotten
beyond that it has been settled and in
writing Fox News did walk back the
claims that they made however we have
also learned for those of us waiting to
see Sean Hannity grovel and apologize or
Tucker Carlson say we were wrong they
are not going to have to do that part of
the settlement is that Fox News will not
have to apologize on air
for broadcasting false claims about
Dominion Business Insider has a very uh
precise write-up about this Dominion
voting system settled its major
defamation lawsuit on Tuesday Fox agreed
to pay Dominion 787 and a half million
and acknowledged that the false claims
were broadcast Fox News hosts will not
be required to issue apologies or
retractions on air per a source speaking
to Insider this is part of the
negotiation which I'm sure was of
critical importance to Fox News now I
know that many of you will say
what is the reason that Dominion would
accept this if that is not going to be
part of the settlement why wouldn't
Dominion insist that there have to be
on-air apologies versus uh allowing Fox
News out of that why wouldn't they say
we're not settling we're going to trial
if you're not going to admit on air and
the reason is very simple and I spoke to
a couple of trial attorneys civil
attorneys about this over the last 24
hours imagine that your Dominion
and you bring a 1.6 billion dollar
lawsuit against Fox News and a whole
bunch of time and resources and money
have been spent just even getting to
trial and you're presented with two
options option number one is you go
through a four to six week trial you
might be confident that you'll get a
verdict in your favor with a nice
settlement but you don't know that for
sure and even if you do you then have to
collect it and there can be appeals and
there can be delays and there can be all
sorts of different things this could
take years
and then you get to collect whatever
you're able to get in a trial or
Fox News just gives you half of what you
ask for and you probably were already
inflating what you asked for at the
beginning knowing that the settlement
might end up being less but but but Fox
won't have to apologize on air
the answer is it depends how ego driven
this is if Dominion is primarily
concerned with the sort of punitive and
humiliating nature of getting Hannity to
apologize on air
then it would make sense to say no that
can't be part of the settlement or we're
going to trial or whatever but my guess
is and it doesn't sound like a crazy
decision to make my guess is Dominion
lawyers said listen
this is a sure bet of nearly 800 million
and we wrap it up quickly and we move
into collecting the 800 million but
they're not going to apologize on air
they will apologize in writing and at
least as far as your future business
with States the apology in writing is
probably pretty good why not just take
the 800 million and get the hell out of
here rather than going forward for weeks
and what could become months or years
before you actually collect I get it I
get it now as a public person who just
has an opinion as to the destructive and
corrosive nature of what Fox News did
around the election on air obviously I
would love to get it's sort of like the
perp walk of sorts right I would love to
see Hannity even if it's a short and and
tersely worded apology of some kind have
to make a statement on air I would enjoy
that it would be great it would be great
for the lulls as the kids like to say
these days but I understand why Dominion
wouldn't hold out for that so for those
those of you who are saying well we're
now going to get that apology the
apology came in writing a fox and the
article mentions this a fox spokesperson
said an email
we acknowledge the Court's rulings
finding certain claims about Dominion to
be false this settlement reflects Fox's
continued commitment to the highest
journalistic standards that's hilarious
we are hopeful that our decision to
resolve this dispute with Dominion
amicably instead of the acrimony of a
divisive trial allows the country to
move forward from these issues so listen
I would have liked to see the apology
we're not going to get it and I
completely understand why Dominion is
not insisting on that one of our
sponsors today is fume not everything in
a bad habit is wrong so instead of a
drastic uncomfortable change why not
just remove the bad part from your habit
fume is an Innovative award-winning
device that does exactly that fume is
not electronic there's no Vapor or
harmful chemicals fume is just a
delicious flavored air that makes
replacing your bad habit easy your fume
comes with an adjustable airflow dial
and is designed with movable Parts which
is great for fidgeting which can be
great for people breaking bad habits
look at what people online are saying
they weren't sure what to expect but
ended up loving the taste and the feel
stopping is something lots of people put
off because it's difficult to do but
switching to fume is easy and enjoyable
there's no reason that you can't be the
next fumes success story head on over to
try fumed dot com and use the code
Pacman to save 10 when you get the
journey pack which comes with the device
and three flavors the link is down below